[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the break room
this is our daily show that keeps you
updated on all the nerdy news you need
to know live from our very own break
room here at new Rockstar headquarters
in an undisclosed location coming up on
the show today Agatha gets a new name
what is it I won't tell you yet but I
will tell you at some point in the show
uh morbius is going digital is it Dawn
Dawn not done it's not done is it Chloe
is it dish soap oh it is Dish and it's
Chloe dish soap uh also we're gonna cast
the DCU because no one else is doing it
so we're gonna jump around get it going
we got to help those boys and girls out
over at WB oh and we have so much so
much more to talk about on the show
today uh I'm Brandon who cares across
the table from me we got Tommy bectober
get bent get bent yeah oh that's a new
hard angle from Tommy like that he's not
[ __ ] around on this Thursday is that
too early
I'm sorry we'll take that out and post
all right cone's been set today there's
been it's been a dark day in the office
and I'm a little edgy okay
speaking of edgy right next to me we got
Jessica don't mess with me Clements is
it because I'm wearing sleeves under my
shirt yeah it's the sleeves she was a
skater girl she said see you later girl
she took a sword and stabbed us all uh
speaking of Sword stabbing a song we're
all wearing the same shirt today isn't
this adorable this is a a sneak preview
for you lucky Breakers your roomies out
there uh this can be a new shirt
available at new rockstarsmerch.com
celebrating the upcoming return of Jesus
Christ no I'm just kidding uh
celebrating Ant-Man in the west Quantum
Mania yeah I thought that was Jesus I
mean I think it's supposed to be a
little nod I'm taking this off right now
to The Woman Upstairs you know what I'm
talking about the
goddess our manager our landlord Gladys
lives above us and she hates the noise
we make she knocks on the floor with a
broom constantly but we won't stop our
rock and roll you can't stop us Gladys
we're here to stay
this is one of a few different designs
we're going to have for Ant-Man the lost
quantumania it's a lot of fun we want we
got him in the office we were so stoked
we wanted to put them on so this is a
Sleek preview for all you folks out
there uh so get ready you can check that
out at new rockstarsmerch.com when it
becomes available but go there now check
out all the merch that's on that site
pick something up for yourself you
deserved it you worked really hard this
week get yourself something nice on me
what I say on me you're paying for it
the week's not over and the week was
short that's right it wasn't I mean this
week has been like uh when you buy those
little phone things at the dollar store
and you put them in water and it becomes
a bigger dog yeah or a towel
this week it's like oh it's a little
tiny week just kidding it's a full-size
week wow you shouldn't have swallowed it
uh let's let's get right together
there's 17 inside of me they were so
cute
I swallowed them all I thought they were
Mike and Ice oh 17 of those pills uh we
don't have an official Redemption today
because we refuse to do it but if you
donate some money I'll tell you a secret
about my life if you want to know a
secret from Tommy yeah send it I'll make
it a good one maybe one I've never told
anyone before so it depends on the price
point though yeah if you've got a secret
and you want to get it out send it
anything over a hundred dollars would be
something I could have been convicted of
a crime for Tommy Tommy I cannot go back
to court uh to testify against you okay
to testify against you yeah I keep
getting subpoenaed you guys all
testified against me yesterday when we
were when those roast Comics came here
to roast the posters yeah yeah uh I'm
not married to Tommy I could say
whatever I wanted that's right Jessica
and I got married in Vegas but we had an
annulled oh yeah oh speaking of it she
said that but I haven't got any
paperwork
we might still be married I'm not
signing nothing you just shout it I'm an
old dude it's done oh God don't tell my
wife oh no
Carrie uh uh let's talk about
um amen the last Quantum yeah let's do
it we're very hyped about it uh but one
thing that's been existing in the MCU
that we're we always have questions
about it's pin particles the PPS if you
will uh we know pin particles they're
the magical MacGuffin uh of the MCU one
of the couple magical mcguffins of the
MCU they first showed up at Ant-Man and
they've been used a lot but what are
they and how do they really work like
how how can Ant-Man punch like a
regular-sized person when he's Tiny But
Hank is still able to keep like a a tank
on his keychain right it's all a little
confusing uh so to kind of tackle this
idea we're going to run down everything
a pin particle can do in the MCU and
then we're going to get into some new
stuff from the comics uh that pin
particles do there and how that might
come into play in Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania uh it's worth mentioning too
uh the people that it's worth mentioning
to the people that we know can make pen
particles right because we saw this a
lot with the super soldier serum where
there was like Erskine made the best
version the the clean version and then
everyone else was trying to make it for
decades and decades and people were
screwing it up and then this guy that
was working with the power broker was
making it but now he's dead and there's
fake super soldier serum and there's
real serum and then there's just the
blood of super soldiers and who knows
what uh but the same thing has kind of
happened with pin particles right yeah
where they were introduced and then we
saw like Darren cross trying to make
that's what got him out of retirement
that's what got him that's what dragging
Hank him back into the Barnacle game
that's right he saw someone trying to
copy his work and he was like faster
jigsaw puzzles and you know playing
Liberace and HBO original movies he's
like nope I gotta be Hank oh that was
Hank Pym playing Liberace Michael
Douglas I think so I like that idea
thing I don't know how to differentiate
the two I think Tim goes into an acting
career baby boy
well in this 616 MCU only Hank Pym can
really make the pimparticles as far as
we've seen uh an alternate universe
Thanos was able to reverse engineer pen
particles from a sample nebula got for
him uh that was like in the what if
staff and then Darren cross made cross
particles you got to put your name on
the particle yeah uh
oh an end game I apologize yes an end
game Thanos was able to reverse engineer
the pen particles that's how they made
his little ship go through the quantum
tunnel uh so that we can have that fun
fight at the end uh Darren cross made
his cross particles personally I get my
cross particles from Jesus Christ you
keep bringing them up I mean I'm wearing
the shirt I can't help you bringing them
up he's near and dear to my heart now I
get CrossFit oh yeah for my cross
particles oh I like that I like cross
stitch because I like to knit
you cross stitch because you like today
cross stitches get crosstalk John you
can highlight that comment all you want
all right we're not gonna read it out
loud but let's just say I'm praying for
one of our comments
one of you has left left the [ __ ] left
the flock and as the Good Shepherd I
will pray for you to return your kingdom
come bring us back we lost Jessica she
may have been raptured I don't know uh
but getting back to the pin particles on
the cross part it goes on uh the cross
particles they kind of drove Darren
cross insane yes uh because they kind of
get to your brain but that's something
that pimp particles could do too I was
looking at the the fandom wikis oh yeah
which I love to do FanDuel by the way
well we can't plug fandom enough now I
know they're friends of the show Friends
of the company Phantom saves my ass
because I talk out of it more than I
talk out of my mouth and fandom is there
to help me make sure I'm not saying
something wrong right or at least I
could correct my mistake so thank you
fandom third grade they bring the
receipts they get the the sources for
stuff so they were talking about how
like Hank designed the Ant-Man suits
helmet to protect from this problem
because you've been like pimp particles
can slowly drive you into oh yeah like
just the act of like messing with the
size of your brain and all that can like
drive you nuts uh and even like pimp
particles can have like an adverse
effect yeah after continuous use on
humans that's why the SP the suit helps
with that a lot uh it helps with like
the helmet helps with your brain and
let's see what helps with your body
um and and Brandon I don't know if we're
if we want to cross modulate our
research but then I also went to the
fandom I put it in the script so I don't
know if we're going to get to that point
later but there also is and that once
you have been exposed to the pin
particles for a long enough period of
time this is all comic has not yet been
established in the MCU although I have a
feeling quantumanium May introduce this
your body will start naturally producing
particles and the in the comics the
laying family line has a predisposition
to produce pin particles at a more
efficient rate and like and and kind of
almost start so that that's kind of the
reason why in the comics that by by a
certain point Scotland doesn't need to
grow or Shrink to do you just do it you
can just do whatever he wants in that
form yeah yeah you can have the strength
of a giant man but it doesn't
necessarily need to turn into Giant it's
just in his body we'll get back to that
again because like the comic stuff is
very interesting what pin particles can
do
um So at their base function right pin
particles in the MCU they increase or
reduce mass density and strength the MCU
does distinguish uh like the increasing
of pin particles the increasing pin
particles from the decreasing pin
particles right we know the colors red
shrinks blue grows that's all you need
to know but they don't distinguish the
strength uh ones from like the mass ones
right right right we don't really know
the difference between those yeah so
like I said in the MCU we don't really
have a consistent answer as to why
Ant-Man can punch like full-sized
Ant-Man Hank Pym you know or by tiny
Ant-Man can throw a human-sized punch
but yet Hank Pym
can shrink the pimlab down to a roller
suitcase and wheel it off without it you
know straining an 80 year old man's uh
trapezius muscle it doesn't weigh the
same amount as uh a building anymore
something with the tank exactly and that
might have something to do with their
absorption of pin particles in their
body perhaps they can maybe they're all
super strong at this point but then we
see other people carry that building
like Sunny Birch carries and he's not
like oh my grind exactly so pin particle
users they can shrink down to very small
sizes because they don't lose any Mass
users retain that level of strength like
we said that's why little Ant-Man can
punch Darren cross in the face and it
really hits them pin particles allow the
user to bypass the square Cube laws of
physics which of course we all know but
if you don't know Google it because I'm
not going to say it out loud now like I
said there's repeated long-term exposure
to pin particles and that can result in
the subject's body naturally producing
its own pin particles in the comics we
have that Hank Pym does that Janet Van
Dyne does that Cassie Lang does that and
then Nadia Van Dyne not introduced but
an Mt favorite to be introduced in this
month oh okay so shout out to master
attainment so then again in the comics
we scroll up a little bit Scott Lang
determined no no I'm down
Scott Lang determined that the particle
is capable affecting not only a user's
size but their strength and durability
so again that's all about retaining this
is how vision is allowed to alter its
density in the comics the pin particles
are what gives Vision his ability to
walk through walls okay yeah that's
right because Hank built Vision yes yes
right yeah okay all right and that's I
mean that's basically the comics work
around of why you know you can shrink
like things can huge buildings shrink
down but they don't weigh as much as a
huge building anymore and then at other
times big things shrink down to little
things and they're super heavy and
unmovable so it's like it's a MacGuffin
like you said or it's a Dewey sex Maki
knife yes I mean we were kind of talking
around the office that maybe like
inorganic versus organic has a different
thing because most of the things that
shrink down and aren't like super heavy
anymore they're inorganic and if and if
we remember the classic episode of big
question where we talked about ant-man's
bowel movements just because he's got
waste moving around his giant man system
when he shrinks back down he doesn't
pass that giant turd no well and I think
the the food stays the same size inside
well atomically it just either it
decreases in density as it gets bigger
and it increases in density as it gets
smaller right so I mean if he eats like
17 years of corn and then shrinks down a
little Ant-Man I'm some dense ass
kernels those are kernels that are like
uh they've turned into those uh those
like super heavy balls that you like
people on Tick Tock trying to move about
the bowel movement that's fine I just
wanted to be with Jessica while we did
this together
I was you know thinking back there we
were talking in the office about the the
inorganic versus organic right you also
have like Scott running across like an
arrow tip and yeah Hawkeye isn't like
drooping yeah right right 125 right he's
probably a little heavier than that
um so I'm wondering if it's just like
the strength stays the the mass changes
yeah because that's fun it would make
sense that it can equally distribute
itself because he's also a man that has
created the only way for us to get into
the quantum realm so what if it's in a
suit it distributes itself too okay
yeah and when it's a building it's a
building like in street that definitely
makes the most sense I think you're
right let's see I think it's got to all
be in the tech right the suit plays off
the particles the particles play off the
suit but if you're just raw dog and pin
particles
anything goes anything goes when you raw
dog the Pim oh my God don't be a fool
wrap your tools your PIN particles your
PIN particles
wrap your particles
uh the idea too that like the pims can
just start making their own particles in
their body that's like a very standard
comic book uh one upsmanship where like
people's powers that were external
become internal yes Tony Stark in the
comics creating extremists which was
different from what it was in the movies
extremist was like the Nano bites of his
suit lived in his body right right uh
and they kind of got there in the movie
where he's just wearing the chess piece
and it all comes out of the chest piece
yeah but in the comics it's like in his
body at one point and he's just like at
any point he can just be like yeah the
suit just like yeah comes out of his
skin what does he do
grotesque
because that's the biggest hole Yeah
I was like is it well for two out of the
three of us on this panel maybe maybe uh
I do have a theory that I want to put
out there and I want to see what you two
think about it uh is it possible that
Janet knew how to make pen particles
while she was in the quantum realm and
was working for king or maybe with Kang
or maybe working above Kang I don't know
but is it possible that that Janet knows
how to make pen particles I think so so
I know this theory has is kind of an
amalgamation that or wait I want to make
sure that you're not about to just say
that no no you haven't you tell me
whatever you want no no I'll tell you
why I think what you're about to say is
what I'm going to say so you say your
thing first then I'll say it okay well
so that could be like her big secret
that she has right uh this movie they
talked about in the press releases and
stuff it's all about like the secrets
families keep from each other and all
that stuff uh so like now that Darren
cross is down in the quantum I'm as
Modoc perhaps his like crust particles
are still not uh where they need to be
they're not good pure pen particles is
like
Tang really needs and he needs it from
like the pims and the wings so mine is
similar to this but this is what I think
I think that Janet does know how to make
pin particles I think she was working
with Kang to make those particles
yeah
all right crazy noise I don't like that
it makes me nervous it's fine it's a
rattlesnake I think she was working with
Kang to make pin particles to get out of
there and then she realized oh this
guy's actually very evil so she
destroyed all of their work and that's
why she so she basically sacrificed
herself once already that's why she was
stuck down there that's why King is
pissed and Kang is going to be he's
going to make a deal with Scott Lang but
if he sees any of those pims he's gonna
be trying to kill them immediately I
think do you think when it like she was
getting so in the second Ant-Man you
know they're calling down to her she's
speaking to them through Scott yeah
using him as basically like a a
walkie-talkie a human walkie-talkie like
Kang was probably like coming she's like
okay he's coming to get me with me
cool he's not you gotta get me out of
here
because they have shown that like uh
Janet you know she can make Quantum
energy with her hands that's how she
kind of helped ghost a little bit is
that that could be like the steps
getting us to like oh yeah I can also
like make pen particles now because I
was in the quantum realm they fused with
my body and now I'm one in the same I'm
a pin particle machine what do you think
I like both of you guys theories I think
they're both very valid do you think
Janet was down there making some
particles trying to make particles to
get out because her husband was leaving
her down there yeah she's all by herself
well I think she's still a scientist so
I think she still knows relatively like
this or it's her last name uh she knows
how to make stuff so yeah I could see
her making it I like the idea of her
making it and then destroying it once
she realized Kang was bad do you think
she ever put like a little sign up on
the lab say we're having a particle
party I need all hands on deck it's
possible Refreshments will be sure
welcome to the pleasure yacht whoa I'm
pretty sure this movie will end with
Janet being like no I'm staying down
here yeah and Hank being like I'm
staying down here too yeah oh being like
what the [ __ ]
I guess I'm an orphan again uh but but I
I think her staying down there might not
be
uh good it might have like nefarious
reasons for her staying down there she
becomes bad she becomes bad or wants to
like it's so interesting
reaches efforts it's interesting because
uh Janet is supposed like in the comics
is there for everyone for everybody she
is always there she is a reasoning
behind a lot of things that happen and
to have that character finally show up
just to be like get back in that Quantum
realm okay so insane yeah I think it
would be pretty insane I want her to
keep showing up and being a valid part
of the team
uh this is another thing that pen
particles can do in the comics that
could come into this movie in some weird
way uh the size reduction in in the
comics of pen particles has to do with
like both the increase and the decrease
of size has to do with like tapping into
like uh extra dimensional space so when
they get big they're acquiring Mass from
the cosmos Dimension that's how they're
able to like get big and when they're
getting small they're like putting Mass
into uh like Mass extensions into extra
dimensional space Oh so it's like
they're almost moving space out of our
Dimension into a different one or vice
versa pulling do you want to go use the
idea that like matters neither created
sure you gotta take it from somewhere
yeah put it somewhere it's got to go
somewhere it can't just so much
Beast also figured out well this is
according to Beast he could be lying to
us he is an animal after and he doesn't
exist yet he doesn't exist in this one
but he figured out that pin particles
can sustain their users while small
eliminating the need for food or air
which is something I was always confused
about because it did seem like you
needed the helmet right to shrink and
grow but then we saw in the second movie
like Scott Lang walking around the
school without a helmet on he's fine
right and then a Hawkeye we saw the
horrifying thing when they Shrunk the
dudes down in the truck yeah and then an
owl took them yeah but they were still
alive inside the truck which wasn't like
sealed up because all of the Pim cars
that can shrink and grow you could
assume that like oh they've got like a
an airlock on them Candy Shop
but not the trust of bros I think
I've been affected by too many particles
yeah I can see Janet being evil on this
because she spent so much time in the
quantum realm it might have messed with
her own brain a little bit damage she
seemed a little kooky when she came back
I agree you know what it could be a long
car
what is the definition of kooky for
Janet well I guess that is
skeptical of going back really into
astrology she starts making decisions
based on people's Moon signs yeah yeah
she came back and she was like what's
your star chart I was like are you a
rising get back down there descending
are you a water it's only a problem if
she's a fire sign if she starts making
crafts out of people's blood and guts
you know like that I know someone that
oh you sent it to me oh no you know
someone why would you bring that up this
woman I need to send it to you people
get off of tickets all the time and you
love it I do love it uh crispy
Christie's sending a Super Chat thank
you crispy what if the quantum realm
messes with your body and deteriorates
your atoms creating mutations
quantumania it makes you go crazy if
those mutations affect your brain again
Janet's a little kooky she was down
there too what that's why modak is
walking down in the round is doing that
Quantum cocaine yeah maybe that's what's
wrong with Darren too like his Modoc I
mean there's a lot wrong with Darren
yeah let's be honest his brain computer
space in that scene yeah he was already
going crazy in in the regular size world
right that was that's true part of the
motivation for his evil decisions coming
from it looks like this
uh part of the the reason for him
becoming the bad guy in that movie was
that like oh his brains broken he's also
too ambitious
um this is we sent out a Super Chat
asking will what if become Canon and
they bring zombies into the 616. I mean
that would be an interesting thing to
discover in this through the quantum
room yeah the virus down there because
like what if posited that the virus came
from like right the US the quantum realm
uh and we know they're gonna make a full
Marvel Zombies I like it animated
presentation that's going to be tv14
it's so hard we did this with talking
dragons when we started talking about
something that we're already like we
were like we're talking about the first
episode of The Last of Us today and I'm
genuinely like why why would they come
into the 616 I was so confused for a
little cordyceps
could you imagine the fungi growing in
the quantum room I think a lot of fun
guys grew in the quantum room all right
Bill Murray How Could You William
Jackson Harper
that's the only two not my gentura
gentura gentor seems class Clark quas
Gringo you're now making up names
Jumanji we've made John go crazy back
there uh Jumanji well one thing we've
always wanted to do besides visit the
quantum realm is have a movie club here
on the break room we've been wanting to
do that uh and our friends at nordvpn
have now made our dreams come true and
they want to help you be a part of our
Movie Club as well this is big it's
happening tomorrow so tonight's your
last chance to get in there uh you might
be asking how is the nordvpn giving us a
movie club well just one click nordvpn
gives you access to films and series
that you may not uh be available in your
for streaming in your current region
nordvpn gives you the ability to switch
your location to one of over 5 400
different servers in over 60 different
countries and if you're ever traveling
abroad in one of those countries or a
different country nordvpn will make sure
you won't miss out on any of your
favorite content while you're away
because you can set it to be like Oh I'm
back home and don't worry about the
bandwidth throttling if you think oh I'm
going to use nordvpn and it's going to
stream slow that's not going to happen
nordvpn gives you the best speed of any
VPN service so your content will be
streaming in that crisp high definition
yeah so for our break removing club that
we're going to do tomorrow yes we're
going to be watching knives out I mean
I've already watched it but we're going
to discuss it tomorrow uh and so this is
your chance to do that it's currently
not streaming here in the US
they won't allow it the government won't
let you see that you try and turn it on
in the U.S you get a red dot on your
forehead like this on my nose but you
think this is from a pimple from my
sleep apnea machine no you're wrong it's
the government you're wrong they buzzed
my nose they buzzed my nose but nice how
is streaming on Netflix Japan so be a
part of the action get nordvpn for
yourself watch knives out and join us
tomorrow for our Movie Club discussion
we're going to talk about knives out
during the show tomorrow you don't want
to miss it pretty riveting questions
about Anna De armas where she lives is
she single will she calls me back uh
we'll keep you safe Anna get your
exclusive nordvpn deal at nordvpn.com
break room you'll get a huge discount
off your nordvpn plan plus a bonus gift
doesn't that sound nice this whole thing
is completely risk-free with nord's
30-day money-back guarantee sounds good
that's nordvpn n-o-r-d vpn.com break
room uh go watch Knives Out join us here
tomorrow it's going to be a lot of fun
uh uh we also want to thank some of our
super Chatters out there uh thank you
Noah precious Thorne uh you caprita
making sure that those snitches get
their cross stitches uh
Christian unpronounceable our day one
God kingdom what does Doctor Doom is the
one who kills Kang in the end well what
if God kingdom
you're big on Doom is he going to show
up in quantumania I don't know I don't
know if Martin Freeman is free to film
that day yeah Ross is Doom we know that
I think at the very end you'll just see
a little green thing of energy
materialized in the quantum realm
your plans are doomed okay
hello King I'm Martin free
he introduces himself as Martin Freeman
I like that I like that thank you
boogies we're all Perry Clemens all you
for the super chats out there thanks so
much uh but now we have to talk about
our headlines let's get into the
headlines
I held for graphic uh we got new images
from the setup Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania uh we got a new one of Kang
looking at the machine we sent him place
an org into in the trailers this weird
little device here I thought this was I
thought this device was like the light
up dude you see walking around oh yeah
like turned sideways but maybe not it
looks like the batteries from the second
Gardens of the game it does Barrel
resemblance to some annulax batteries Mt
has talked about that a lot
um and I think I believe Eric's working
on a video of what he thinks that little
machine could be and how why why Kang is
working so hard on it I think it's like
the what Lego are in the quantum realm
he's just building a little thing he's
just having a little fun a little down
time uh uh so we'll see what Eric has to
say about that theory and we'll tear it
apart here on the break room no just
kidding we'll love it uh Joe Locke
posted a photo to his Instagram from the
set of Agatha Covenant of chaos now this
picture shows a chair with Agnes of West
view on the back
are they changing the name of the show I
think sometimes they just do fun you
know shows have uh you know fake titles
or they have all inset jokes kind of
working titles or even like the
production company's name like might be
named Agnes of Westview like the
specific production company obviously
it's Disney and Marvel but you know so I
think that's just a cheeky little fun
chicken maybe they bought these before
they came that's what I'm wondering and
especially since we know it's just
starting production maybe they're being
funny and they're like hey she's still
in bed
so let's we also don't know if that is
Catherine Hans chair and it's like her
says Agnes of West few and then like the
other chair says like Dottie of Westview
or something I don't know they worked
really hard on the chance the little boy
unfortunately shared that image and then
someone said
yeah get out of here uh I hope they're
not changing the name again because it
was House of hardness and coming up cast
now I keep calling it Covenant of Chaos
House of Harkness a dove oven I don't
know the dove oven
I call it Rise of the Guardians the owls
of God
bring it back bring it back folks uh I'm
hyped for this one this next headline oh
God Disney is finally moving forward
with Tron three baby following the other
ones yes that's right that's right
they're not rebooting they keep the
story going oh my God John Legacy was
not a reboot it's been too long it's the
sequel it was a sequel the film will
star Dr Michael morbius himself and will
be helmed by Pirates of the Caribbean
and five director uh Joe Kim roning this
will be the first film in the tron verse
since 2010's Tron legacy the movie is
set to be titled Tron Aries
for all my what are those
what is going on I believe it's Tron
Aries it is Aries Aries
uh now for you park heads out there
Disney World stop it yeah the Magic
Kingdom in Orlando Florida they're
launching the Tron light cycle ride I
can't wait April 4th 2023 Get Hype uh
just tomorrow ready to ride it I'm
almost out of time you're almost out of
time I better hop on my light cycle uh
so tron's coming back maybe I I don't
know you guys you know a lot of smack
talks about Tron legacy maybe a lot of
uncanny valley with the young Jeff
Bridges in that movie but the technology
has come a long way we could tweak it a
little bit but you guys cannot deny the
soundtrack for that come on Daft Punk
will they come back together today the
soundtrack for Tron Aries they must I
don't know I don't know they're up all
night to write the soundtrack to Tron
Aries
oh I think that was the song Perfect uh
and a new trailer for screen six just
dropped today and if you're a big screen
fan our very own Whitney Bank laningham
is working very hard at breaking down
all the crazy details and connections to
the Past films so we'll have her trailer
breakdown on the channel tomorrow so be
sure to check out for that there's a lot
packed into this one oh my God Trophy
Room there's like a room full of Easter
eggs and missable details just for us uh
but I don't know you guys you like
horror movies are you on you into the
scream franchise like the screen I love
old school is it too self-referential is
that the problem for you no after the I
think I stopped or I didn't stop I
stopped being like the biggest fan of it
after the fourth after the fourth was
when I was like okay after Hayden
Panettiere I was like and I said I'm
only a SIM for scream five oh okay I'm a
jack Quade guy you like just scream just
scream oh the music is well I mean
scream screen screen five was screen
it's green it's great and now they're at
screen six I thought it was man because
I gotta stream Falls of the E and uh I
think the a in Scream 4 was wow that was
a ram
scream for him the man that wrote I
think screamed three I think scream
three I think it was scream I think yeah
bless your Dasher sweet sweet Dasher
um he wrote a new horror movie called
sick and I think it's just now coming
out and it is a phenomenal scale and
there's like the movie within the scream
verse right called like stab yeah stab
stab uh I like I don't like horror
movies but I do like kind of the Scream
movies still are more fun they're more
fun because they're always like oh it
can be it over the top they're big yeah
yeah yeah and it's so silly it's not
it's always a different ghost face right
always a different Ghost Face uh he's
got a great theory about who this ghost
face is I yeah you guys gotta check out
Whitney's video she's got got some
scream theories that are going to make
you yell
dream was right
oh
really
fun we have had several super Chatters
so I am going to share a few oh do some
super chats
I uh you can create that for your Super
Chat I'll confess that I still sleep
with a nightlight
Tara isn't here uh for your Super Chat
I'll confess that uh uh in the shower I
often have our uh fictional arguments
with people that I always win oh that's
nice
[Music]
I'll confess that I have never seen the
movie The Godfather 2. uh
one and three all right only three
and uh that's it for now that's it for
now play the graphic again John
little secrets
yes now after Jim Gunn mentioned working
on his girl with his Guardians of the
Galaxy Pals at his new job we decided
we'd scour his Twitter always a good
choice especially if you go back to like
2016.
and then we fought we looked at all the
images he's posted of DC characters that
he's tweeted out over the last few
months and we said okay he's talking
about his friends from Guardians of the
Galaxy so we assume it's those movies
and he was an executive producer on both
the Avengers Infinity war and end game
so we could stretch for that but let's
take a look at the DC characters he's
posted and cast them with his old
friends from Guardians of the Galaxy
does that make sense to you guys yeah
yeah yeah you're gonna write them on our
whiteboards in reveal so what's our
first one up there John
we've got dead man okay now for those of
us that let's give a quick primer dead
man was I believe a trapeze artist who
fell to his death and in the beginning
of the comics it was just kind of scary
but in the more recent justice league
dark movies has been kind of a funny
weird almost a Ryan Reynolds fourth wall
breaking kind of like I'm telling jokes
to the camera
so cast your dead man okay I gotcha
I think for dead man now this this is an
actor who you can pick for any of these
because he's guaranteed to get one of
them yeah ladies and gentlemen
it's a nepo baby it's Shawn Gunn wow
I think it's see him uh playing this
kind of weird character
I chose David Batista Bautista because
he kind of has the same
damn dude damn or you can let me finish
David uh he has the same kind of
storyline as
um uh Ghost Rider Ghost I think oh got
it as ghost writer and I just think it's
funny that he's like a ghost that has to
go back and do a bunch of things and I
think Dave Batista would do a good job
okay uh I'm going with a little bit of a
Dark Horse candy just because of the
humor the sarcasm having fun mugging to
the camera I think Brad Cooper would
make a great oh Braddy Cooper cast Brad
Cooper is dead man cowards to a ball
okay let's what's our next one John
oh Damian Wayne and Batman Okay so this
was I'm sorry no no I don't know okay so
Damien Wayne Uh was Dave Bruce Wayne's
son that he had with Talia this is the
real sign okay yes this is his son they
have what I would say a a less than
harmonious relationship through a lot of
the uh Comics but uh Bruce eventually
learns to you know take him in his route
he doesn't want to be Robin because he
wanted to get hurt but he settles in on
it so let's just cast our Damien Wayne
they're all family
you got one no I'm trying to think of
the second really quick
okay I probably spelled this wrong
which is sad
John C Reilly oh is Damian Wayne yes but
he's a very grown-up Damian way okay I
like that older Wayne come on dad
Jessica I'll go what you're thinking if
you want yeah are you upset no okay so
I'm gonna go with a cross I'm gonna
gender bend Damian Wayne to Damian Wayne
oh with the girl who played young Gamora
and Josh Brolin is Batman oh okay I see
I see what you're going for there yeah
that images Damien trying to kill Batman
I mean I think he's thinking I said
Sylvester Stallone as Batman
clementov yeah is she is she playing uh
a female like a Damien Wayne or is she
playing a boy yeah she could I think she
could play a young boy
I was actually imagine just mantis in
that room
mates is killing Batman yeah stunning
all right next one
Gorilla Grodd okay
I think this one that's a John C Riley I
like this one's another gun favorite for
me I think this is again I think he does
I think he goes practical they put him
in a little suit you get Michael Rooker
oh okay okay I like that I like that
super intelligent ape uh I'm rolling
it's so hard for me to Remember actors
names I'm so sorry I'm doing yondu
that's Michael Rooker all right
fabulous I'm sorry uh invitation is the
purest form of flattery I I would say I
would say Dave Batista Batista would be
a great girl or Vin Diesel you could do
Vin Diesel then would be Vin voice for
Gorilla Grodd would be freaking awesome
gorilla guy grug
yeah speaks English yeah he he has like
uh he's a smart gorilla he's kind of
like I mean I don't without I'm not a as
a verse in this as uh many other things
but like he's kind of like rocket in
that he's like a Genetically Enhanced
animal that like can speak I think he
speaks through telekinesis maybe or tele
now is there another smart ape in DC
Comics isn't there another one I mean
some would say that um Batman's been a
little bullish at times
I feel like there was another song
if you know the answer Colin Colin we
got another one John I think we got one
more at least two more oh this is uh Mr
terrific who we saw uh on the show Arrow
played by Echo Keller oh okay okay
[Music]
what are there any black Manning
Guardians not on my watch
uh no there's a that's a quote from Mad
Men ah do we have any
drinking this office that's on my watch
that's what this is yeah yeah of course
he doesn't the guy that plays um uh uh
ronan's running the accusers oh yeah
Diamond Hansen yes well you know what we
could go outside the box here let's go
let's go the infinity war and end game
movies too because this is just I mean
is there a lot of makeup involved in Mr
I think it's just over his face no and
he has his little spheres a little
magical terrific balls if that's the
case if it's pretty terrific balls
what's my nickname all right if it's
that simple of makeup I think I think
James gone is gonna give this actor a
little time off from too much makeup and
just a nice simple jacket a little mask
Zoe Saldana baby wow Miss terrific she
could still be Mr terrific yes I like
okay what if she gets a prosthetic nose
uh she did that when she was playing
Simon Simone so that's why I said it um
I can't spell his name right Yaya
oh yeah yeah who's gonna be uh the high
evolutionary
wonder man yeah he's Wonder Man High
evolutionary is uh I also can't
pronounce his name
yes yes yes I got them all mixed up
don't say it like that
I mean do you have someone
I'm gonna go
you know what this is representing A
diversity problem in the casting of
these films but I'm gonna go Daniel
Caillou okay that's a good one
from the Black Panther film which James
gonna have nothing to do with uh that's
a nice role for him all right next one
you coward
so is this for Superman are we casting
yeah I think we're fantastic Santa Claus
Superman who else do I see in there uh
is are those the Wonder Twins on the
bottom right I can't call it if they are
let's just do Superman we're fan casting
Superman from the DC or from the
Guardians universe and I'm gonna go with
something oh I got a great one
okay
oh that's a good one who wants to go uh
someone that's not me all right you want
to go Brandon yeah I'll go okay uh I got
two options for this okay first one is
the best one Glenn Close baby yes put
our Superman or Vin Diesel let Vin
Diesel be Superman no yeah let him do it
I thought Vin Diesel Superman would be
great until I realized Lee Pace could be
simple oh that is a good one pace would
be a freaky
so good he would be an incredible
Superman why haven't I thought of this
call in when it happens James I'm
gunning for your job you can't change
your answer now I didn't change it
um mine says Chris Pratt oh so what are
you doing
so there was no wrong answers well you
know what there are we are worshiping
Chris Pratt's savior on our shirts today
so wait no it's a different one it's a
different one we're a different one ah
Kang is an awesome gang may he rang in
the quantum realm all right speaking of
uh and I will crank you up on a Time
chair
go ahead
is selling time shares uh Mikey cheers
had an interesting super chat if DC
reboots using Flashpoint Paradox uh they
would only need a younger looking
Superman temporarily
which is fine we know that James Gunna
said they want to do a Superman movie
like a year one Superman he's in the
city he's got a job Mom and Pop can't
are back at the farm he knows he can fly
he probably has a suit
let's see it I like it uh uh Kristen
unpronounceable sending a secret super
chat they're omitting their secrets
they've never seen E.T the
Extraterrestrial Bambi Titanic or any
Godfather movie uh a lot of those are
understood I forgive the last three I
guess technically five if you count the
Godfather Coda and part two uh you gotta
see E.T Christian please I can't that
movie's so good can you see the version
where they still have the guns that's
right yeah get it get your hands on a
little bit of just tape a movie have
been juicing that that's embarrassing uh
Memento I've never seen Memento I've
never seen Memento maybe break room
Movie Club maybe Breakers are good
friends what's your what's your movie
you've never seen that it's very
shameful let's hear it I still haven't
seen Doom
come on
I just never had time to see it in
theaters and then when you're at home
you're never like I'm gonna sit down for
four hours you know what I have a phrase
Dune is for goons Batman is for cat it's
good that you admitted your cat
no I hate cats I'm a dog it's good that
you admitted your your Dune Blank Spot
while Zach was not here yeah because I
thought this was the same space while
Zach wasn't watching when we talk about
it I let Zach get it all out and there's
Zach's in the chat I'm just kidding uh
before we head out here's another
interesting Super Chat point that kind
of ties into our conversation today
Marilyn Jay was asking if we think the
quantum ROM has any relevance to
Deadpool slash cables time traveling
watch
we've talked about this a little bit
yeah we have talked about this I think
it's so weird to it's it's not weird
it's not weird at all for it to affect
them but I think it's them gonna affect
or for them to affect us I think it's us
affecting them and I think they're going
to use can you scroll back up oh yeah
I'm sorry I think it's oh it's gonna I
think it's going to affect them in a way
that it's like their time travel
bracelets gonna go out of whack and then
they're gonna just switch into a
different completely new timeline which
is a the mcu's timeline but we talked
about this briefly I think it also more
affects not the quantum realm I think it
has a lot to do with uh Doctor Strange's
like spelling Wanda's spells and all
those things that happen in Multiverse
and Madness well it's all going to like
tie into it yeah I think that's going to
tie in more to what Deadpool and cable
are doing because that that doesn't make
sense because you know we've talked
about pimp particles today and they've
obviously been used for time travel but
as we've talked about them in the office
right we see the the pin particles
aren't the only way to do time travel
right right and the time travel is
really you know the Einstein Rosen
bridge and the quantum realm the the pin
particles are like the fuel for your car
to do that right like you need those but
there's other ways to drive down this
road maybe you don't have a car maybe
you got a motorcycle and that motorcycle
is the time door from the TVA or maybe
you have a semi truck and that's the
watch a jet ski or a jet ski and you
shouldn't be on the road get off the
road what are you doing uh zmix sent in
a super chat with their own DCU casting
oh here here's what they had Dave
Batista is banzo as Bane Bane Bane yeah
as Bane
yeah
Batgirl yeah all right
uh Bradley Cooper has Nightwing which I
would love to see like an adult yeah
Grayson where he like yeah yeah he kind
of retires his Nightwing secret but yeah
and he's like Dick Grayson he's like an
FBI basically James Bond because we have
so much Batman stuff going around no
give me an origin Nightwing please I
will that's the only one origin okay but
it's gonna take a year now Batman Batman
adopts a 45 year old man no hear me out
that'll be Nightwing never uh they
shower together anyways uh excuse me Vin
Diesel has Clayface which I think is
an actor yeah yeah yeah right and Chris
Brown gets nothing oh poor friend dude
and you get damn nothing damn dude and
Mark asked Mark to ask Marcus Marquez
Marcus Green gets the name of the day
award
they have a very personal question for
us what was our first jobs and they said
love from Indiana my wife's from Indiana
what what parts are you you ever stop at
Gray's Cafeteria stop it you ever gone
to the John Mellencamp field house at
the University of Indiana
have you ever been to Walmart
uh I don't know I mean my family uh were
I have part of my family's Farmers so my
first job was uh forced forced labor on
the farm interesting uh uh what was your
first uh my first like real job my first
government was taking a piece of my
paycheck yeah I worked in the box office
for a local dinner theater selling
ticket packages as a young high schooler
wow my first second credit card numbers
over the phone oh write them down using
them later
Comics uh my first job was Jamba Juice
Jamba Juice what goes babe don't talk
hey was that the secret menu I don't
know that wasn't there
and if you guys didn't come in with no
it's not no that might be orange julius
oh my apologies every time I go into
Jamba Juice I'm like triggered from
being yelled at for making drinks wrong
what was your first job tell me back I
actually got hired at two jobs at the
same time uh I got my workers permit
which again
huh
oh okay great it is but I think I think
it was a kid there was a drink and there
was a cartoon character called yeah
that's right so I got hired at a uh
Apple Farm working at a bag apples and
potatoes and weighed them out and then I
also worked at a summer camp those are
good I loved being a camp counselor you
are working on that apple farm where
they like where'd you get all these
[ __ ] potatoes from this is the apple
pie I said where did you find these
potatoes I don't want to know what was
like a farmer's market that we they
would bring everything in and then we'd
be banging them up in the back bring
them out front nice little bag little
box of berries a little cider in the
winter
[Music]
are you pushing uh you know I was
pushing carts full of apples what was
your first job uh leave it in the chat
for us we'll check them all out and
we'll uh tell you whether we like your
jobs or not tomorrow Applebee's no thank
you it'll be a job roast guys good job
Bros but most importantly tomorrow is
our movie club uh we'll have our normal
show but we're gonna have a little
segment where we talk about uh get a
Knives Out not getting out we'll talk
about that later we're gonna talk about
knives out so if you haven't watched it
uh get yourself a nordvpn a trial on us
use our code use the link in the
description watch Knives Out join us
tomorrow we got lots to say about it
it's gonna be great this should make a
sequel to that movie I think I don't
know but thank you for tuning in today
like we said check out the channel lots
of great videos coming up uh tomorrow
we'll have Whitney's breakdown of the
screen trailer oh yeah check that out
some awesome uh videos coming up over
any other videos coming out oh we got
lots of videos coming on the channel
over the weekend uh more Kang stuff
Tommy's got a video coming out today
yeah
he's got a great uh Theory I'll call it
a theory yeah it's basically me
explaining who's outside that door or
facing off against the Jedis and Amanda
oh yes if you saw the Mandalorian 3
trailer yeah uh there's a shot looks
like Order 66 someone's trying to get to
our boy grow goo you know people say
it's a theory I say it's an absolute oh
he's banking on it you could put money
on Vegas on this one bad boy that's
right uh and if you're watching The Last
of Us it's awesome uh check us out on
the channel we won't be back on Monday
because we're doing uh our a special
episode of the break room Sunday night
after the last of us a little after show
me Jessica Clemens in advance and gonna
be great really looking forward to it uh
we hope you have a great rest of your
Thursday thank you for joining us today
you could be anywhere on the internet
but here you are right now having a good
time with later skaters I'll be the same
goodbye Breakers goodbye roomies we'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]